[Music]
you
you want to be able to keep your stret
seal
Integrity without it
breaking keep
[Music]
it
keep the structural Integrity keep that
sphere of
influence this way you can get on the
other side of the
grip okay if you're if I'm over here I'm
on this side of the grip but I want to
get on the other side of the grip I
spill over the top
oh okay
realize realize the fingers are part of
her energy so her fingers are going back
towards her okay so don't pull don't
pull against them this is not
[Music]
AO
use
it see I'm now underneath her
fingers it's not so much that I'm
throwing her is that she can't she can't
hold on to the arm that's kind of more
the
intention but by that I mean she can't
stop the arm you understand okay so if
if I'm gra if I'm here be strong be
strong she can do it but go ahead if I
change the
angle she can't do it you guys see that
so we're trying to generate that angle
we we don't want to push an angle
because the same angle that I can push
on she can push on so I have to change
it I have my lateral me right my
rotational directional Harmony my sphere
of influence all right and now here I'm
going to work off the back foot the back
foot is going to create a body alignment
that can make my hand heavy so I have to
push off the back
foot back foot moves
me back foot I engage
it I start to move
he's going to grab right okay and I I
feel his size that you want that people
are going to resist on you but that is
telling you where I need to go it
doesn't tell you that's what I push on
that's what you ride around so when you
start to drive right oh there's his
weight you see but I go over the top I
start to go over the top then I start to
go
down
so yeah you come around okay oh I can
feel I feel those fingers so I start to
turn it you see oh that was easy okay
now I'm going to start to try and go
forward oh I oh oh I feel his weight
okay so I reach out and I start to go
down
so I'm T to put the foot in watch my
watch my new rear foot so front foot
this this is my rear foot right so I T
boom right in the back so I can get that
new
power okay let's go why need grab
okay you have to be able to relate your
elbow to your
hip right but it can't be from you right
doing this you understand it's it's just
locked in place it's locked right here
my lat and my my torso muscles are
extending so they can't come in okay
they're extending out
[Music]
out then I keep that outwardness see I
don't do this I keep my shoulders spread
now I drop my hip in the Triangle so
here's the bottom of the triangle the
top is over on the other side of his hip
and this your hip that's where I step
in
open you can you see this triangle where
I'm going to go we're going to go over
here okay that's where I
drop don't step out of your
grip this
no this is a line the line doesn't work
when he's going flying by you because
he'll pass
me you want a circle to your Technique
and the circle is really a spinning
triangle okay so you
rotate so it's kind of like he's going
to go around me
you guys understand when I'm a triangle
but imagine you have a triangle with an
axis in the middle you spin it it's
going to replicate a rotational energy a
circle okay so that's what I'm trying to
do he's trying to
go around
me he's not passing me in the
night so I don't want to just change
direction I go this way and then I go
that way no that's not going to work
you make that spinning triangle
W the spinning triangle will bring the
weight back to your Center you see cuz
my
hand is I'm not as heavy out there as I
am here underneath my Center so I put my
Center so my hand gets back to my Center
underneath it spinning
triangle
[Music]
okay let's
go
right right
he get your g hi
something